今日のテーマはそれほど難しくはならないと思いますが
社会と道徳の関係というところと
我々はこの社会の中でどうやってまともな人間で生きていられるのかという 2つのポイントなんです
社会というのはなかなかいいものだとちょっと言い切れないんですね
とにかく悪いことに誘惑されるし
大変ですよ どちらかというと悪いことする人々は結構元気で生活しているように
成功しているようにも見られるし
ですから 社会と道徳というのはかみ合わないということは明らかなことなんですね
だからその現状は何なのかと
それから社会があるんだからと我々悪いことしちゃうと
我々の心が汚れちゃうし
我々はどうすればいいかっていう 2つのポイントなんです
だから この まあちょっとふざけた言葉でモラリティスリップリマインドということ書いたんですけど
まあリプリマインドっていうのはいい加減にしなさいという叱ることなんです
結局道徳が叱られてるんだと
道徳が叱るのは普通なんですけどね
世の中のこと考えると道徳がもうやられているんですね
いい加減にしなさいということで
はい それでこの 1番目のポイントはこの道徳っていうのは社会の人間が自分で変えられると考えているんですね
ほとんど読み上げるだけで十分やと思います今日は
倫理道徳は自分で変えられるものだと思われている
みんなこのなんか権力を持ってるみたいですね
社会は 好き勝手に変えられると
道徳は それで人間は決して皆同一意見になったことはないので
道徳は変えられてもいいんだけど
人間というのは一人一人別な意見を持ってるんだから
倫理道徳は常に曖昧な状態なのです
ずいぶんこの倫理道徳っていうのは未だに曖昧なんですね
はっきりしないんですよ
嘘を言ってもいいのか悪いのか
時々によって場合によって嘘を言ったらいいでしょうかどうか
みんなそれぞれ違う意見を持ってるんです
倫理の必要性を疑われているが
本心ではないのです 社会は倫理っていうのは大変必要なものだとは言ってはいますよ
誰でも 声高くして でも言ってる人からみんな一生懸命破ってるんですね
だから本心言ってるわけじゃないんです
はい それからこの道徳変えると言っても
誰が変えるのかと 社会といっても具体的に
誰が変えるのかということを勉強した方がいいと思います
で まあ 第1位若者新世代
これはみんなもう言いたいでしょうね
若者新世代はやっぱり古い価値観をもう壊してしまいますよと
2番目は大人 大人も結構やってますよ
で 大人だからね もう価値観もう全然無視して大胆な行動をする
3番目は権力者 権力者といえば
政治的な権力者も経済的な権力者も両方いるんですよ
だから金持ち人に怖くて我々悪いことする場合もあります
で アメリカが言うことは誰でもやっているのは
それは政治的経済的権力を持ってるんだからなんですね
別にアメリカ自体がそんなに金がある国じゃないんだけど
この世界経済は支配管理しているんですから
やっぱり経済的力を持ってますから
我々は言う通りにやるしかもうどうしようもないんですよ
悪いことをやれと言ったってもやるしかないんです
命が危ないんです だからそういうことで
この権力者っていうのは
まあ小さな社会でもどこでもいて
経済的な力を持って あるいは政治的な力を持って
自分好き勝手に社会を変えようとする
4番目は宗教家 宗教家も道徳の守る組織なのはずなんですけど
もうくたくた破ってるんですよ
で  5番目は暴力主義者はね
これは明らかにわかりやすいんですね
暴力主義といった途端ね
社会のモラルを守りたくないっていうことだから
で  6番目は偏った知識人
頭もいろんなくだらんことを勉強して
もうこればっかしで物事を考える
普遍性がないんですよ
例えば哲学を勉強していたならば
そこの面だけで世の中を世の中を見る
生の人間を見ないとする
科学者だったらその目だけで世の中を見るとかね
まあそうやってこの偏った知識人たちも
まあ結構道徳を殴ってるんです
はい それで一々説明していきます
若者新世代にいじめられる道徳が
大人が普遍的に悩む問題
これは大人がよくもう今今の若者はという一言葉っていうのはもう結構口癖になってるぐらいね
だから大人が悩んでるんですね
自立したいという戦いですが
経験と知識が浅いなので
それほど影響を与えることはできません
若者のこの道徳に逆らうこと
社会のモラルに逆らうことはそんなに大胆な問題じゃないんですよ
あのグループは自立したいだけなんです
どうせ自立しなくちゃいけないんだから
まあ十六とかね まあ十五からね
もうなってくると もう大体今日本だったらもう十四歳からもう結構もうかなりいい加減わがままでもう逆らうんですよ
まあそこはもう二十歳になるぐらいまでは続くんですね
彼らが別にどうったことなくて自立しようとしているんですよ
だから時々社会のモラルは壊すんですよ
壊しても経験はないわ
知識はないわ ただまだまだ子供だから
別にそんなに社会に大胆に影響を与えませんよ
我々大人が偉そうに心配していても
若者はそれほど道徳には攻撃はしないんです
ほとんどの場合は大人の世界に戻る
その時期が変わったら何のこともなく大人しくなるんです
ですから そんなに問題はありません
大人社会が自分の利益のために新世代を
自我主義の自我主義を応援する場合もあります
これがとても危ないんですよ
例えば若者にいろんな悪いことを押し付けているのは大人なんですよ
漫画やら映画やらあらゆるファッションやら
もう麻薬やら何でも で
若者に売れることしか考えてないんですよ
本であろうとも何であろうとも
それでも若者っていうのは当てにならない
もうもう子供でしょうに
だから親に逆らえ逆らってると思っちゃえば何でもやっちゃうんですよ
それだけのことなんです
だからそれをうまく商売にしているんでしょ
世界が 大人が これがとても危険なことで
若者が悪いのは もう本当にもう社会の大人のせいなんですよ
だって家を出たらいくらでも悪いことできるように
もう社会は待ち構えている
それで金儲かるんだから
子供を売春にしちゃうわとかね
大人が売春しなきゃどうやって子供は体売るんですかね
大人が尻を蹴って家に帰れと言えば
この野郎何やってるのかと
みんな子供だから怯えますよ
でもそうじゃないでしょ
もうタレントとしてもう受け取る取るわ
あれ 何て言いますか あれは
町か町で あのスカウトするとかね
そんなことになってくると
もう田舎の子供たちもやっぱり自分も人気者になりたいとかね
もうタレントになりたいとか思うのは普通でしょう
それでさーっと来るんですよ
だからその場合は若者に文句言うんじゃなくて
大人が自分自身に何か一言言った方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
はい 次に行きます 大人にいじめられる道徳倫理
大人にいじめられる二番目
で 大人の場合は自分の生き方を維持するために
大体自分の生き方を維持したいんですね
もう大人だからもうもう取り返しつかないということもありますから
やっぱりやってる悪いことをずっとしょうがないではないかと
私はこういう仕事だから
こういうことで食べてるんだからという風にも維持しようとして
道徳破る 社会とうまく調整して生きるために
それもう一つ言い訳にするのは
もう社会と調整しないと
もう生きていられませんよと言って
大人が社会と調整しようとして
もう社会がやってる悪いことを自分でもやってしまうんですね
自分が何でも知る大人だと勘違いしているため
またもう一つの問題っていうのは
大人になったらもう偉そうに
もう何でも知ってると
だから悪いことしたら
誰かが言ったら これはおじいさんどうでしょうかと
お前何知ってるんでしょうかと
これで何も悪くはないんだよと
言って ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ説明するんですよ
例えば昨日もそういう質問ありましたけど
まあ嘘も方便だと仏教で言ってるんではないかと
だからもう完全に嘘は悪いとは言いたいのですかと
だから別にそれには適切に答えましたけど
仏教は嘘は方便だと言ってないし
それはえらい勘違いであるし
私の答えは嘘は方便だと言ったのは
この頭が悪くて想像力がない
嘘をつきたくてたまらない人々のウガガとであって
これは決して仏教の方便じゃないんだと
どこにもないんですよ
大乗経典にも ないんだけど
堂々と社会にその言葉が行き渡っている
どれほど大人社会悪いのかというと
だからとにかく大人っていうのは人殺しは良くないんだけど
場合によって殺さなくちゃあかんではないかとかね
日本は平和憲法かも知りませんだけど
もし北朝鮮が爆弾でもミサイルでも撃ち込んだらどうするのか
だから我々もそれをもう開発して
もう待ち構えていなくちゃいけないんではないかとか
そうやってこの昨日読んだ冊子でも徹底的に軍事力を持てという記事がありましたけどね
で まあそういうふうな大人がやっぱり道徳を破ろうということを応援するんですよ
なんかすごい知識人に見えるんですよ
私はそれ勘違いやと思ってる
言ってるんです 思ってるんじゃなくて
大人の それから習慣 慣習
伝統 文化などを守る 維持するためにという
これも大人がよく背負ってる問題なんですね
これが習慣だとかね これはもう慣習やと
もう何とか言ってやっちゃうとかね
例えば日本の社会は酒飲んで大変病気になったり
問題を起こしたり 事故を起こしたり
事件を起こしたりとかね
もう酒の粗で ものすごい人が死んでるんですよ
事故を起こすたびに もう酒飲んでるんです
なのに もう法律も違反でしょうにね
酒気帯び運転は なのにもうやっちゃうっていうのは
もう習慣だからとか 日本の伝統だからとか
なんとか言い訳するんです
それから文化とか何とか言ってね
偉そうなことを言って
もうやっちゃうんですね
そこで最後は他人に 社会にコントロールされているため
また腰抜けの大人がもういつでも他人にコントロールされてるんですよ
はいはいマンで イエスマンで
何でも言う通りにやる
そういう性格だったら
けしからん大人ですけど
もう何のこと躊躇もなく悪いことしちゃうんですね
まあそんなことで大人が道徳を破っていじめているんです
まあ破るっていうことはそんなに問題ではありません
誰でも道徳っていうのはもう完全に守ってないんだから
それはそんなに問題じゃないんです
人は誰でも間違いはする
こちらで私が言いたいのは
間違いをすることじゃないんです
人間だからもうまあスリスリなんか間違いを起こすということはそんなに大事な問題ではありません
それもちょっと気づけばね
ああ やっぱり失敗しました
気をつけますと それだけで十分ですよ
問題は この主義で しょうがないではないかという
その一言葉なんですよ
文化だから こんなこと言ったって文化でしょ
我々の と あの正当化することがものすごい最悪
もう大罪なんです 私がそれやっちゃったっていうのは何のこともないんですよ
人間が弱いんだからね
そこら辺は別に大目に見てあげても何のこともないんです
社会でみんなやってるんだから
社会に合わないといけないんではないかと言っちゃうと
その人は救われませんよ
極悪人です だからよく区別してほしいのは
私たち個人個人では もう何とか何とか何とか悪いことをしてしまうということはありますよ
それはそんなに悪人ということになりません
自分でそれを反省する
自分が間違っていると認める
道徳は道徳であると 間違ったのは私だよと
そういうぐらいでいい人間なんです
お釈迦様もそれをそのままおっしゃっていることなんですよ
間違いを起こさない人間を作るということはちょっと無理不可能
全知全能がないんだから
人間に 知らんことはいっぱいあるし
だから間違いを犯してしまって
犯さない人間を作るのは
もうもう完全悟り開くまではもうもう不可能ですよ
無理です それではなくて
人間に言ってるのは まあ間違いを犯したら素直に認めなさいよ
道徳攻撃するなよ それすごく優しく見てるんですよ
もうもうやれやれとね
例えば子供がなんとか失敗したら
ちっちゃな子供は誰も怒らないでしょうね
やれやれやっちゃったんでしょうがと言って
もう片付けてあげるだけでしょう
だからまあ大人の世界にいたっても
心から見れば幼稚だから
まあそこら辺は仏教はすごい優しく見ているんです
しかし 開き直っちゃうと
これがもうしょうがないんではないかと
その一言葉で罪はもう消えなくなるんです
それが言いたいところで
はい 次に行きます これで権力者にいじめられる道徳っていうのは
これはあまり複雑な大きな問題で
あまり大げさにはしゃべりたくないんですけど
政治家が自分の権力を維持したい
だから自分の権力を維持するために
平気で悪いことをする
政治家の場合は危ないのは
国民にも言い張っちゃう
国連でもそれを言い張る
他の国々にも強引に行ってもう賛同してもらう
参加してもらうという
だからとても危険で怖いもので
我々一般人にはどうすることもできないんですね
これは単なる自分の権力を維持したいだけなんですね
経済的権力者は自分の利益を維持したい
そこでもう 今最近 薬に対していろいろ文句言われていますけど
今までずっと体にいいんだ
体にいいんだとかね ずっと言っていた薬というのは本当に悪いんだと
いくつかの薬を言われています
あの薬の名前何でしたっけ？あの子供に使う精神安定剤
プロダック  プロダックじゃない
リタリンのですか  あ プロゼック
で まあそれそれカタカナ
プロゼックという PRZAC
なんです 発音 文字はそれは
あの精神安定剤で これは子供にも与えてもいいやと
ずっと長い間与えてきて
これ大変なことになるんだと
これは脳にはとても良くないんだと
脳の発達は遅れるんだと
もう後でもうまとめな研究者たちが研究してレポート出してるんですよ
それ薬作る会社が何用なのかというと
こんなネズミ実験とかなんとかやっても
それはもう正しいデータになりませんと堂々と言うんです
どれほど自分の利益を守ろうと思っているのかというと
どれほど屁理屈かというと
どんな薬にもネズミ実験をやってからでしょう
人間に推薦しているのは
ネズミやら動物やらね
まあそこまで実験してからでしょうに
だから自分たちもこの薬はいいやつ嫌って言ってること自体もネズミ実験の結果でしょうに
なんでもっと詳しく同じ研究をやったところで悪いと言うんですかね
何の根拠もなくデータが足らん足らんとかね
例えばこの劣化ウランの爆弾を落として落として
ものすごい被曝してるんですよ
イラク人が それでイラク人だけじゃなくて
アメリカ人も何人かが被曝しているんです
それで明らかな証拠はあるんですよ
しかし アメリカ政府と軍隊は絶対認めない
そんなのは科学的なデータではございませんと言うんです
だからもう 100人  300人ぐらい死んでからですよ
やむをえず認めるのは
なぜかというと それ認めちゃうと
もう金がかかるんですね
それは政治的に批判を受けるんですよ
今もずっともうあの劣化ウランといって
もう原子爆弾ばっかり落としてるんです
結局はウランはウランだから原子爆弾には変わりはないんです
日本でもどこかで山に練習撃ってるやってるみたいんですけど
わからない 場所はわかりませんだけど
どこか山に遠くから撃ってるみたい
人が住んでない山っていう島ですけど
劣化ウランで使ってる
まあだから我々には何の文句言ったって何の力もないんだけど
私は道徳的な立場から言いたいだけなんです
別に政治家のことに何か言ってるわけではなくて
まあこういう権力者は
まあ労働と道徳をなぜ破るのかというと
自分の権力が経済力を守るために維持するためなんです
それでこの権力者はこう思ってるんですよ
他人は自分に管理コントロールできる存在だと思ってるんです
三菱会社の人だって もうあなた方のことを何やという態度なんですよ
それで欠陥の車作ったりする
であのあのあの英利の問題を受けたでしょう
あの輸血で輸血でしたっけね
血液を受けたところでね
それであの加熱処理しない薬でもまあいいよ
使ってくださいと言った教授が権力者なんですよ
他の医者たちが怖いんです
あの教授には もう一番トップだから
彼の一言葉でもう大変ですからね
研究する人々は自分の仕事を
なんとかのところで仕事欲しいんだけど
もう卒業してからはこの人推薦しないと
それからどこがどこかで日本の会社でももう加熱処理しないで薬作ってるんです
これが危ないっていうことは知ってるの
アメリカからデータが来ているのに
平気でもする 裁判でもすごく威張って
もう言いたい放題のこと言ったりするって
だからいかに人殺してるんですけど
権力者っていうのは経済
あれ単なる経済的なことなんですよ
もう儲けが減るんだという
そういうことで 我々はもうもうもう何て言います
芋みたいな感じで もうカモみたいな感じで
好き勝手に何でもできると思っているところが危ないんです
だからまあ国民といったっても
一般人っていうのは本当にもう腰抜けて声は上げないし
反論しないし だからもうやられっぱなしの状態になってます
それでやがて私たちも同じ船に乗っちゃうんですよ
悪いことしたっても まあいいんじゃないかという
で この人々はマスコミ経済だけではなく
宗教まで支配して一般人を自由に操るというふうになっています
マスコミは完全に支配されています
経済も支配されています
権力者にそれで終わらない
宗教まで支配されています
だから宗教が言うこともほとんど当てにならないんです
権力者の経済的な権力を持っている人の機嫌を取ろうとしているのです
だから悪いことを平気で正当化する
あまり詳しい具体的な例を言っちゃうとちょっとまずいんだから
まあそこら辺はちょっと省略します
はい 次に あの  我々の世界だからね
ここら辺は詳しいことを言ってもいいと思います
宗教が導かれる道徳倫理
まあそこで宗教家は強引に押し付けて
道徳に対する演奏印象を悪くするんですよ
まあ一番いい例というのはイスラム教なんです
ものすごい強引 イスラムの国々に行ったら
自分がイスラム教でなくても
もう断食する時は食べてはいけないわとかね
もうあれ大変強引なんですよ
イスラムでない人でも
女の人とどこかで喋っていて
見つけたら お前ら二人結婚してないでしょ
だからもうもうもう刑務所やと
もうもう10分の裁判で刑務所に入れたりする
そんなことでその宗教の印象が良くなるわけないでしょうに
だからまあ自分の信徒
信徒さんにしても仏教も同じですよ
あまり強引に道徳なんか押し付けちゃうと人間嫌がるんです
それで道徳っていうのは嫌なもんやと思っちゃうんですね
そういう宗教が真剣になりすぎちゃって
というか アホでどちらかわからないんだけど
人々を道徳の道から追い出すんですよ
あまりにも強引に押し付けて
次に神の言葉 聖書 開祖のお言葉などを利用にして脅すだけで
押し付ける道徳には説得力がない
ただ我々は脅す 脅されているだけ
これは神の言葉だよと
お前何言うのかと そうすると無言で我々は受け取らなくちゃいけない
あるいは聖書に書いてるんではないかと
あるいはこれは開祖の言葉だよと
言葉じゃなくてお言葉だよ
だから自由な人間が だから何をという疑問を持たなくちゃいけないんでしょうと
持たせません そのまま信じなさいと
そういうことで まあ人が宗教から離れるのは決して問題はありませんだけど
道徳の道から離れるのはとても危険なんです
宗教なんかあってもなくても
人間はそんなに損しませんだけど
道徳の道から外れちゃうと大変危険なんですよ
だから宗教家は これは聖書に書いてるんだよとか言うだけで
もうこれだから悪いんだよと
こういうわけで良くないんだよという風に
このもう人々を説得しないんですね
次に 聖書拠点などを勝手に解釈する
そこでこの宗教家たちが好き勝手に聖書の言葉
聖書っていう場合は一つじゃなくてたくさんありますよ
各宗教は聖書を持っているんです
仏教とインドのもう一つの宗教以外は
だからこの まあ仏教の場合は経典ということになる
仏教やジャイナ教の場合は経典という言葉になってますけど
経典という場合は正直なところで宗教を開発した人が喋った言葉ですよと
だからそこら辺は親切な単語なんですが
それでも勝手に解説すると
解説する人が開祖様ではないし
聖書解説する人は神様ではないし
ただの人間でしょう だからその人間の脳細胞で処理して出せると
もう汚れてるんですよ
それでも世界が大変混乱に陥ってしまいます
だからほとんどこの宗教から道徳を侵された歴史っていうのはいくらでもあるでしょうね
その時もほとんど解説ですよ
例えば輸血は絶対するなよという
ある宗教団体が言い張っていたでしょうね
それで子供が死んじゃうんですね
それキリスト教の信仰宗教団体なんですけど
しかし 聖書には一句も書いてないんですよ
聖書の人々知らなかったんだから
そんな治療法あるということさえも
一言も書いてないのに
これ否定する 彼らの論理は
神は完全たるものである
神は間違いを起こすはずがありません
だからなんで人が人に血液を渡るんですかと
これは神を冒涜することであると
その解説はその組織のその新興宗教団体の考え方なんですよ
それで結構人が死んだりするんですよ
そうするとみんなあの宗教は嫌だなとかね
あの宗教組織は変だなとか思うでしょうに
そう思うのはいいんだけど
ついでに人間道徳世界そのものを否定しちゃうんです
だからそこら辺は良くないということなんです
自分が道徳を犯している場合は
それを教理学的に正当化する
これよくあるんですよ
宗教家も結構道徳を犯すんですよ
で 大胆に で まあこの小さな小さな誤りっていうのは
仏教では全然もう問題にはしません
まあ仏教の場合は人殺しとかね
まあ 4つぐらいありますよ
項目は 絶対いかなる場合でもやってはいけない
例えば出家の場合なんですよ
まあ他はちょっとちょっと間違ったらもうすぐもう懺悔してもうやり直せということで
で 弱みを認めるんだけど
いくら弱いからといってこの項目だけは破るなよというふうな
この上限ありますよ で
仏教ではだいたいそういうことはもう破ることはしてないし
したこともないし しかし
他の宗教ではもう堂々と自分の聖書に逆らって
で 悪いことをする  できれば英語の本がありますよ
Bad Pops という本がありまして
作者かなり研究されて書いてるイギリス人の方なんですけど
もし読めればね どれぐらいこのポープ様たちがね
昔の今じゃなくてね もうとんでもないことをやっていたかと
それでなんで堂々とそういうことをやるのかという疑問には
彼がポープだから 天国の鍵が彼が握ってるんだから
間違いはないんだと 彼にだけは
そんなこと言っていいのかと
一人で罪を犯すのはいいんだけど
他の人にやらせるんでしょうし
だからその場合は自分が悪いことする宗教家が宗教を引用しながら引用しながら
聖書を引用しながら引用しながら
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ解説して世間に言う
例えば今起きているこの自爆テロ行為
ジハドという行為も同じ
いい加減な解説の結果なんですよ
あのインドネシアの人いるんで逮捕しちゃったんですけど
堂々と言うんですよ イスラム人は世界で負けるはずがないんだと
我々が正しい神を信仰しているんだから
あなた方が悪いんだと
負けてるの あなた方は負けていること自体は神に対して失礼だと
だからとことん戦って
やりたい放題でもやって
もうイスラムを世界中に広げておかなきゃいけないんだと
そんなちょっとおっかないんだけど
そう言うのは その人が大変有名
大変信仰されている宗教家なんで
イマムなんですよ イラン
インドネシアの起きた大きな爆弾テロとは彼の指示なんです
バリ島ではとかね いくつか起きたんですよ
それでも彼は逮捕できないんです
別に彼がただ説法 私は説法してるだけだというんだから
それでもインドネシア政府はイスラム政府なんですが
もう一応逮捕はしたんですけど
まあ裁判でも逃げるでしょう
何のことなく だからそれはその宗教のことで我々に関係ないんだけど
私の普遍的なポイントは
宗教家が自分が罪を犯すために宗教を使うんですよ
そこで一般人が 素人の信徒さんたちが専門家の解説を信じるしかないんですよ
それがまたすごい危険なことなんです
例えば仏教にしたって
私は専門家で 私はごちゃごちゃ解説しちゃうと
皆様にはこれ違うんじゃないかとちょっと言えないでしょうに
そうすると私はあんた何言うんですか？と
私は専門家だよと言っちゃうと
ここで話が終わりでしょうね
だからその危険性もなんとか直さなくちゃいけない
仏教で直してますよ 常識に訴えなさいと
たとえ私が 私はしませんだけど
時々自分の解説しますよ
その時はちゃんと言います
これが私の解説ですがと
はっきり言います 言わない場合はずっと経典参照しながら言ってるんです
お釈迦様の場合は自分の常識に当てはめてみなさいと
だからいくら宗教家がへんとか
みんなわんこうして人は罪に罪を犯すために応援してても
自分の良心 自分の 心に
常識に訴えてみれば これって悪いとわかるんでしょうに
その場合は抗議してほしいと
例えば麻原さんが殺せと言ったところであの愚か者たちが自分の良心に自分の常識に訴えてなかったんですよ
そこで問題が起きたんです
なんか偉そうに東大出ているんだ
京大出ているんだとかね
言ってるんですけど もう頭が悪いのはもう明らかなもうことでしょうね
常識失っちゃうと何の東大ですかね
東大出たってもハーバード出たっても意味がないでしょうに
オックスフォード出たってもイェール大学出たっても
良心常識を失っちゃえばもうイカれてるだけなんです
だから宗教家がすっごい強引に一方的に独裁的に言っても
お釈迦様いうのは自分の良心と常識をに合わせてみなさい
お釈迦様がこのカーラーマプッタというカーラーマ村の人々に道徳を語る時でも
それからもう一つのブラマン人の村で同じ教典二回繰り返してます
道徳を語る時でもはっきりと言ったんです
あなた方は聖書にあるんだから信じるなかれ
神の言葉だからといっても信じるなかれ
論理的だからといっても信じるなかれ
伝統だからといっても信じるなかれ
まあ古い本に書かれているんだからといっても信じるなかれ
それは一つの あの なんて言いますか
信じるための証拠になりませんと
ヤダトゥンメカーラーマアッタナウジャーネーヤ
君たちは自分たちの常識で知ったならば
これが悪いと これが正しいと
それを認めなさいよと言って
それからお釈迦様の道徳を言っていくんです
最後に私は結構有名な人気にも
舎門だからといって お釈迦様というのはインド社会ではもうかなり強烈な影響力を持っていたんだから
ただ私が舎門が言ってるんだからといって信じるな
だからこの宗教家が道徳を侵すことっていうのは
お釈迦様は遠い昔 ちゃんとよく理解して
その問題もきちんと解決してあるんです
仏教では はい 次に行きます
二番目 原理主義などを作って宗教は社会に嫌われるものにする
そこでまた宗教家っていうのは原理主義っていうものをへんてこりんなことを作るんですよ
このなんで原理主義を作るのかというと
誰かいじめるためなんですよ
誰かを差別するためなんですよ
それでまた状況の立場が悪くなるんですね
戦争などを教理学的に解説する
信仰などをもって正当化する
賛成する それで戦争ももう宗教家からも正しいと言うんですよ
で あのイラクの前 あの本当にじりじりと戦争をしていた時は
あのアメリカ側のビデオしか流れませんだけど
あの牧師さんたちがいるんですよ
で もう彼らがもうみんなにお祈りしてあげて祝福するんですね
ある黒人の牧師ですけど
いうのは This is acceptable
This war is allowed
そういう言葉を使うんですね
この戦争は正しいんだと
やってもいいやと 言っても
イラク人であろうとアメリカ人であろうと
人が死んでるでしょうに
戦争っていうのは人殺し行為でしょうに
どうやって聖書でそれは acceptable と言えるんでしょうかね
だから私は言いたいんですよ
私ほどあの人は聖書を知らないんです
そんな acceptable war というのは成り立ちませんよ
聖書では 特に新約聖書では
なのに堂々と言う だから私は自分の常識に訴えながら読んでいるんだから
そういうことは読み取れません
それはまあ信仰を持ってね
まあ正当化すると 日本もやりましたからね
次に 宗教・信仰の違いによって道徳も異なるので
人類にとっては一貫性は持たない
これはもう関係あれとは関係ないポイントなんです
宗教はそれぞれ違うでしょ
信仰それぞれ違うでしょ
だから語っている道徳も違うんですよ
それで一般の人類から見ると道徳に一貫性がないんですよ
豚肉食べていいのか悪いのか
牛肉食べていいのか悪いのか分かりますかね
牛肉食べちゃうとヒンドゥー教だったらとんでもないことなんですよ
地獄に落ちるとは言わないんですけど
もうすごいとんでもないことではあるんです
豚肉食べたらもうユダヤ教とイスラム教では絶対天国なんかは行けませんよ
体全身が魂まで不浄になっちゃったんだから
それそう思っていて ではキリスト教の方々
みんな地獄に行くんでしょうかね
だから宗教によってこのバラバラ道徳を言ってるんだから
一貫性がないんですよ
そうすると一般人にとっては
何やこれというね 気分にはなりますよ
それも宗教が社会に与えている大きな社会ではなくて
道徳に与えている大きなダメージなんです
社会と別格の存在になろうとするから
ほとんど相手にされない
これはそんなに難しいポイントじゃないんですよ
宗教家っていうのは 私たちは別格の人間だと
聖なる人間であると 威張り合って威張ったくなっていますからね
ここから入るなよとかね
あれこれやとか まあ日本の仏教にしてもなかなかいっぱいありますし
他の宗教でも結構あるし
そんなことを威張ったと一般人が無視しちゃうんです
相手にしないんです ああそうですかと
だからもう宗教家がなんで社会と別格になろうとしているんですかと
神様になり上がろうとしているんですかと
なんでみんなと一緒にご飯食べて苦しみ
苦しんで生活は苦しいんだから
しないのかと その問題はまあキリスト教の一部一部は気づいていて
やっぱり一般人と一緒にいなくちゃいけないという考え方も一部にはあります
特にカトリック教の中でもね
まあ神父さんたちもシスターたちも
まあ何のおしゃれも何もなく
ごく普通に一般の人々と一緒に生活して
一緒に苦しんで なんとか助けてあげようとしている
その場合はその宗教は好きになるんですよ
また最近読んだ記事で
アメリカ人の女の人なんですけど
まあおばさんになってからね
やることはなくて まあシスターになっちゃったんです
それでこのメキシコに行って刑務所に住んでるんだと
もう 17 年間刑務所と
それで特別は使い何もいらんと
で ずっとメキシコの刑務所だから楽じゃないでしょうね
で それでそちらにいる人々に宗教を教えたり
面倒を見てあげたり 何か喧嘩したら怪我したら治療してあげたり
過去過去はナースでしたからね
で 怒鳴ったり いろんなことをやっていて
彼女はもう怒っちゃうと
犯罪者たちでもみんなもうすぐ言うことを聞いてくれるんだと
それでまあ刑務所の人々も警察もみんな大変彼女のおかげで助かっているんだと
彼女も同じ刑務所の自分の部屋で
もう板の上で寝て ずっと長い間生活している
それで彼女にもやっぱり自分のところに来て
シスターになってなりたいと思っている人々もいるんですよ
だからそうやってあのシスターが一般人と一緒にいるんだから
他の人々も あ 我々もまともな人間になった方がいいんじゃないのかと
この人は贅沢できればできる人ではないか
でもやってないんだと
いうことで 宗教に対する共感も持つし
道徳を守ってまともな人間になろうとするんですよ
それはある一つの宗教のことではなくて
どんな宗教にも同じことなんです
だからこの それも欲 道徳に対してえらい迷惑なんです
迷惑は宗教がかかっているんです
はい またあるんですね
二つで終わったと思ったんですけど
一つの宗教の中でも一貫性はない
これはよくわかるでしょう
仏教にしたっても 必ず宗派があってお互い何言ってるのかやっぱりわからない
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃとかね
これが宗派を作ったせいで
まあまあ キリスト教にしたっても一貫性はない
宗派があるはあるわ あのイスラム教にしたっても一貫性はない
スンニ派とシーア派がお互いに殺し合いやっている
で 威張ってます 唯一の神アッラーのみを信仰しますとかね
偉そうなことを言いながら
お互いに殺し合いやっている
この宗教の中では一貫性ないっていうことは大きな問題です
したがって 宗派が現れて混乱が生じる
宗教の歴史に 特に仏教
道徳を軽減する 無視する傾向が強い
宗教の宗教史の中でも
他宗教は置いておいても
他宗教はそんなに厳しい道徳を言ってないんだから
もう厳密に道徳を語っている仏教にしたっても
時代とともに軽減しようと軽視しようとしているんですよ
無視する傾向が強いね
例えば出家は決して再婚してはいけない
ところがもういかなる場合も性的な行為はしてはいけないとあるのに
再婚して何が悪いのかと
というところまで進んでいるんです
で 韓国の大乗のお坊さんたちは一応真面目にはいたんですけど
どんどんもう日本に倣って
もう結婚してもいいというふうなことになっちゃって
また宗派分かれてるんです
全く結婚しないお坊さんたちと
もう結婚して酒飲んで
もう何でもやるお坊さんというグループが出てくるんです
宗派が で 仏教の場合はとにかくこの道徳を否定するだけでなく
ブッダの教えまで否定することになっておるんですよ
例えば開祖様の教えになってくると
ブッダは間違えけど この宗派の開祖様こそブッダだと堂々と言うんです
そうやって宗教の世界で
もう道徳はもうひどくクタクタ砕かれているんです
それで私の定義はね これは本当はいい加減な定義なんですけど
守りたくないものは道徳であるという定義から見ると
宗教も例外ではない だから宗教を信仰している人々も結局人間だから
私のいい加減な定義は守りたくないものは道徳であると
だからその人間も宗教被ってはいるんだけど
裏中は人間だからね で
守りたくないという気持ちはあるんですよ
だから宗派作ったりして道徳を破ったりする
宗教家だから社会に対する影響は強い
問題はそれなんですよ
[背景音楽]社会に対する影響は強い
はい これで恐らく終わりと思います
はい 暴力主義者にいじめられる道徳心理
これ宗教の世界終わりました
で 暴力主義者に まあまあ生き延びるために暴力を手段にするのは原始時代の生き方ですが
その習慣は現代人にも現れる場合がある
あのね この暴力を振るって自分の命を守るということは
この原始時代のことなんですよ
だから自分の洞窟の中にいる何人かしか人間いるとも知らないでしょ
だから獣見たら倒すか倒されるか
どちらかでしょ そこで他のどこかの森からなんか人間なんとか出てくると
わからないんですよ 人間かと
互いに怯えるんですよ
それで殺しちゃうんです
殺して食べたりもするんです
それはもうこの猿からずっと開発した
そのそこの時代の人間の生き方なんですよ
しかし もう進化しているんだから
いい加減に猿の生活習慣やめればいいでしょ
でも時々現れるんです
その人々ですよ この暴力主義者っていうのは
あの原始時代にあった我々の習慣がちょっと現れてくるんです
彼らは違法的な生き方が正しいと真面目に思っている
暴力団とかね 暴力 マフィアとか
いろいろ もう中国だったら邪道ですか
あの人々は真面目に信じてますよ
これこそ正しいんだと
だからその暴力団の中で結構厳しいんですからね
しきたり 道徳 ものすごい厳しいんです
真面目なバカたちなんですよ
というか原始人なんですよ
弱い社会が怯えて従うことがあっても影響力はない
まあ我々は怖いんだけどね
でも全然そんな影響力はないんですよ
宗教家ほどは マフィアには社会に影響を与えることはできませんよ
巨大な組織かもしれませんだけど
中国の邪道もなかなか大変ですけど
社会の道徳を壊してしまうところまでは影響はないんです
しかし 我々は怖いことは確かに怖いんですよ
しかし 新世代の一部に影響を与えることは可能です
新世代のまだまだ原始的な人間が現れちゃうと
すぐそちらに入っちゃうんです
だから普通常識で言えば暴力団はとんでもないと言いたいでしょう
でも私の解説ではもうあの価値観逆なんです
新世代の道徳を犯すことも
暴力団の道徳を犯すことも
まあ私はそんなに大変な問題では見ないんです
本当に迷惑なんですけど
若者がやってることはどうしたことはないんだけど
暴力団っていうのは本当に迷惑なんですけど
でも道徳全体にそんなに影響を与えません
その連中は法律で捕まっても叩いちゃえばいいんですよ
もう あるいは私が言った一言が原始人だと
だから学校で子供たちに
暴力好きな子供たちに怒鳴ることではなくて
君たちは知っているのか
我々は猿から進化したものやと
だから時々動物的な本能も隠れていて
たまたま現れますよと
でもそれはみっともないんだよと
我々は今 21世紀で IT時代で生きている文明人だと
だからその動物的な本能が現れても
すぐそれを潰してくださいよということを教えてあげれば
いわゆる暴力を振るのは原始人やということは
子供たちが納得しちゃうとカッコ悪いということになるでしょう
子供たちはカッコ悪いことをしませんだからね
面白いことを 何やってもかっこいいでやってるんです
だからまあそれがかっこ悪いと教えてあげれば
大体は解決しますよ すごい単純です
しかし 宗教家がやっていることはそんな簡単だと思いますかね
簡単じゃない 政治家やることはそう簡単じゃないです
はい で 仮説として知識人にいじめられる道徳倫理
科学哲学などを勉強して
それこそ真理だと思ってしまう
自分の偏見により道徳を否定する
個人が知っているものは知るべきもののすべてではないということに微妙に気づかない
この知識人たちは 時々ね
言うでしょう 例えば私は輪廻転生の話をすると
そんなのはありえませんと
どうやってその人言ってるんでしょうかね
自分が知ってることすべて？どう見たっても人間知ってるものはすべてじゃないでしょうに
我々は知識を得ると一部しか知識を得られないでしょうに
化学の人は化学しか知らないし
医学の人は医学のことしか知らないし
演奏家は演奏家の能力しか持ってないし
だから知識っていうのは一部っていうことは当たり前なのに
これに微妙に気づかないところ面白いでしょう
自分知ってるものは全てだと思って
科学者が宗教まで解説しようとする
冗談じゃないんだけど
それよくあるんです まあ時々影響力はありますよ
例えば有名な科学者が
ノーベル賞を取った人とかね
非道徳的なことを言っちゃうと
それは危ないんですよ
守りたくないものを知識で打ち砕く
その人は何をするのかというと
我々は守りたくないものは道徳だから
ただ単に反対するだけなんですけど
知識人はそれは知識で打ち砕くだけ
大した差がないんです
はい 次 これで次のテーマというかチャプターなんですけど
なぜ道徳を道徳論議がいじめられるということですね
人が守りたくないものは道徳であるから
理性ではなく感情に支配されて生きている
1番目はこの守りたいものを守りたくないものが道徳でしょう
だからいじめられるのは当たり前なんです
いじめられて不思議じゃないんですよ
これが当然です  2番目は
我々は理性で生きているんじゃないんですよ
人間っていうのは感情で生きてるんです
例えば理性で生きてるんだったら
たとえ怒っても人を殺してはいけないでしょう
理性なら たとえ自分の家に火をつけても
犯人の家に火をつけちゃいけないでしょ
しかし そうはいかないんですよ
犯人 自分に家に火をつけた放火犯人見つけたら
警察に見つかる前に自分で行ってその人の家に火をつけちゃうんです
それが感情ですよ だから人間が感情で生きてるんだから
道徳はいじめられちゃうんです
他人が守ってくるなら自分も助かるから否定はしないが
いじめはする 例えば他人が嘘言わないなら
他人が泥棒しないなら
他人が空き巣に入らないなら
他人が悪口言わないなら自分が助かるでしょ
他人が道徳を守ってくれるんだったら
例えば自分の子供でも正直で真面目で素直で嘘つかないで
何だかんだ親に言うならば親が助かるでしょ
だから道徳を否定しないんですよ
他人が守ってくれるんだから
なら しかし自分ではやりたい放題いじめるんです
道徳を 道徳について高度な知恵で徹底分析したことはありません
世の中でいまだに道徳というのは何なのか
本当に世の中であるものか
生命の中で存在する事実なのかという
徹底分析はいまだにない
しかし これはブッダ以外です
ブッダはやってるんだから
私はこういう講義やってます
初めて道徳論というのがあるんだよと
否定できないすごい厳しい道徳はあるんだよと
はい それからまあ 生きにくい社会というテーマに進みます
まあほとんど読むだけで自分は止めますけどもね
これはすごい簡単なことを言ってます
個人が道徳をいじめてる
したがって道徳が義を持たず賛成されていないのです
社会から見ると 個人って個人がね
道徳をいじめているでしょ
だからこの道徳に賛成されてないんですね
本当は 皆様 正直に考えてください
自分はもう賛成しているのかと
やっぱりそれなりに嘘を言う必要もあると思いますでしょ
会社にしたっても それなりに誤魔化したり
仕事をサボったりする必要あると思ってるでしょ
確定申告はいろいろ誤魔化したりしなきゃ全部取られとると思ってるんじゃないの？だから正直に言えば
やっぱり我々は義を持たず賛成してないんです
他人が道徳を破ると自分には迷惑
それだけは発見しています
仕事も家族も自分自身も
の命さえも決して安全ではない
この世の中で もし人が道徳を守ってくれないと
ならね 子供を誘拐されて殺されたでしょうに
それからもうなんか誰か誰か誘拐しようとしたっていう
あの未遂事件もあったでしょうに
危ないんですよ もう生きていられない
人が道徳守らないと自分の仕事が危ないんですよ
家族も危ない だから他人が道徳を守らないと本当に危ないんですよ
だから社会は生きにくいんです
危なくてたまらんですよ
他人の不正について常に怒りを抱きつつ生きることになる
それで我々は道徳で喋るでしょ
いっそでも私は一旦言って言い続けますから
我々は他人の道徳について指をさしてますよ
あの人は道徳を守ってない
あの人は嘘をついている
あの人は人を殺している
あの人が不正しているとすーっと言い続けているんですね
そんなことでなんで言ってるのかと
自分には迷惑なんです
皆様が住んでる家の隣
道徳を守らない恐ろしい精神的にちょっと異常な人がいると不安で危ないでしょ
もし自分の子供を誘拐して殺す可能性もあるでしょうに
だから他人が道徳を守らないということはとても危険なことで
それで私たちは何するのかというと
すーっとブーブーと文句言ってるんです
なんでこの世の中こんな風になってるんでしょうかね
悪くなる一方ではないかとかね
人は信頼できないんではないかとかね
あれやこれやとかね そうやって私たち人間みんな怒りを抱き生きてますよ
道徳の場合です これすごい大きな問題なんですよ
だからお釈迦様はその問題をどう解決するのかというと
他人に指さすなよと 道徳は他人に守ってもらうものじゃないんだと
あなたが守るものだと
あなたが守ったらあなたが安全だよと
あなたはこういう風になるんだよと
他人に指を差そうとした時点から
我々はすごい怒り 批判
文句 そんなもので心がいっぱいになるんです
例えば電車に乗ったら
電車に乗ってる人がちょっと行儀が悪かったとする
そうするとイライラするんですね
なんでこの人々はもう大人しくしないのかとかね
そんなことはどうでもいいんだから
私は大人しくするぞと思っちゃえば落ち着きますよ
だから この他人に道徳
他人の道徳のことばっかり気にしているんだから
過去人が道徳のせいで怒り
憎しみ 不満 不平の気持ちでずっと悩んでるんです
それが誰も気づいてないで問題ですよ
どこにもどんな本にも誰も書いてないんです
そのポイントを はい 次見ます
個人が正直に生きようとして
これは個人の問題 正直に生きようとしても
周りから攻撃される 一人の人が正直に真面目にやろうと思っても
周りがゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャ言うんですよ
道徳を守るとしても言うんですよ
調子に乗るんじゃないやとかね
あれこれやという 皆様から聞いたもう悩みなんですけど
酒やめたいんだけどなかなか
やめられない 本人に勇気がないわけじゃないんですよ
仕事をしているんだから
仕事は後の隙間にやるんだから
だからその悩みはどこから生まれてくるかというと
その人が本気で真面目に辞めたいんだけど
この社会は道徳を守らせてくれないんですね
酒はそんな大きく大きな道徳問題というよりも
例えば会社で不正をしている一人の社員がこれはダメだと私はやりませんと思っちゃうとやられちゃいますよ
いろいろラベルごまかしたり
国産牛肉でないのに国産牛肉と書いたり
いろんなことをやっていて
これに反対しちゃうと首が飛んじゃうし
だから社会は道徳を守らせてくれないという個人問題があります
悪をしなさいと脅しも誘惑もある
そんな風なことで この日本の会社でいろいろ事件が起きたでしょう
道徳的な その場合は 結局は社員たちは脅されているんですよ
あるいは誘惑もありますね
これちょっとちょっとごまかしちゃうと 100万円手に入るぞとかね
そういう誘惑もあるんだから
みんななかなか個人は道徳を守れない
仲間外れにされる時もある
道徳を守ろうとしちゃうと仲間外れにもなる
皆と一緒でないと追い抜かれるという気もする
自分は社会競争で失敗するという気もある
自分が素直で真面目でいると
この激しい社会競争で自分がもう失敗するかも
追い抜かれるかも だから
善も悪も問わずやらなくちゃあかんではないかということに個人が思っちゃうんです
それは個人に関わる問題なんです
はい で 社会に問題はつきものという別なタイトルなんです
社会っていうのは問題はつきものなんです
二人がかそれ以上人間が互いに関係を持つ
持って生きる組織は社会です
で 私は定義までしなくちゃいけないんだから
これ疲れますよ これが社会の定義なんです
なぜかというと この世間の単語をあまり仏教は使わないんです
仏教には仏教的な定義があるんです
これで社会の定義なんです
二人かそれ以上の人間が互いに関係を持って生きるならば
それが社会です 皆様方の言語では
社会というとすごく大きくてつかみどころのないものでしょ
それじゃないんで 仏教では
はっきりしている組織なんです
仲間 家族 クラス クラブ
会社 村 町 国などの様々な社会がある
そうすると社会っていうのは管理できない無制限の曖昧なものじゃないでしょうに
仏教的に見てください
夫婦だけの社会  [笑い]とかあるでしょうね
二人だけの社会 あるいは夫婦と子供一人がいて
その三人の社会 それは家族社会でしょ
あるいは仲間作ったりして
例えば私みたいに全然結婚も何もしない
一人で生活している人にも誰かが仲間が出るかもしれません
友達が 例えば二人で色々一緒に買い物したり
一緒にご飯食べたりしたり
生活できます それもまた社会なんです
それで様々な社会がある
クラスが一つの社会 学校と言えばそれまた一つの社会
クラブで言えば また学校の中で別な社会でしょ
大学でも学校の中でクラブありますからね
それまた別な社会 そうやって社会っていうのは本当に定義がある
リミットがあるものなんです
で 村といえばまた制限があるでしょ？街と言えばまた制限があるでしょ
国 そのものを社会と言ったっても制限があります
それから国と国の社会もあるでしょ
この G7 やらあれやこれやとかね
いかに世界の国々をいじめるかという目的で組み合っている社会があるでしょ
どのように上手に搾取するのかと
まあいろいろありますよ
その場合はここにいくつか賛成すると
はい 小さな社会ではトラブルが少ないとしても
社会は様々な問題を抱えている
そこで夫婦社会にしてもトラブル問題がある
家族社会にしてもトラブルが問題がある
小さな社会の問題っていうのはそんなにどうったことはないんですよ
二人で一緒に生活していて
トラブルが起きても まだなんとかなんとか話し合って仲直りできます
で 大きくなってくると
トラブルっていうのはなかなかそう簡単には解決しません
例えば国同士でトラブル起きちゃうと
そう簡単には解決しません
しかし いかなる社会にもトラブルはつきものです
それだけ痛い はい 次 今日は終わらないみたい
たくさんあります 社会の問題は倫理的に説明できる
メンバーたちは決まりを守らない
他の人々のために行動するより
自分の勝手に行動する
それが他のメンバーの迷惑になる
だいたい社会の問題というのは
私は倫理的にも説明できると言っているんです
なぜ社会に問題あるのかというと
誰かが道徳を守らないんです
自分勝手に行動する それがトラブルなんですよ
例えば夫婦だけの社会であっても
一人が自分勝手に行動しちゃうと
これがトラブルなんですよ
相手に迷惑なんです それだけのことなんです
とにかくまとまらない
社会っていうのは 自分一人の考えで生きながら
社会のメンバーでもいようとすることに
なんとかわからない 打ち間違いだと思いますけど
ところ？することに まあとにかく社会っていうのはまとまらないもので
この社会の中で適当に直してください
一人が自分勝手に行動しようとする
例えば家族社会で言いましょう
家族の中で一人の子供が我が物好き勝手に生きようとする
しながら家族の一人でもいたいんですよ
これでトラブルんですよ
私は勝手にするんだから
もう二度とこの家に戻れませんよと言って
永久的に家出て出てしまえば問題ないでしょ
残された人々に ではないんですよ
暴力振りながら家で寝るんです
家のご飯食べるんですよ
そこを書きたかったんです
だからそれで道徳守られてないんですね
はい 次 また元に戻ります
生きにくい社会っていうこと 3
番目 で これ考えてください Just
think yourself
自分で考えてください
これはなぜなのかと 人間は本来道徳倫理を軽視する傾向ですということから
しかし この態度はどれほど社会に損害を与えているかとほとんど気にしない
道徳は勝手に軽視するんだけど
それによってどれほど社会に迷惑かと誰も考えたことがない
それから皆様考えてください
なぜかと 警察 裁判 セキュリティシステムなどにどれほど費用がかかるのかと
地球規模で考えてください
警察やら裁判やら裁判制度
セキュリティシステムなどなどにどれほどお金がかかって困っているのか
それからなぜ この次は日本語の言葉はわからないことを英語で書いちゃったんですけど
文体っていうことなんですね
と呼ぶんですけどね まあ軍事力
で なぜ軍隊が必要なのかと
考えてください もうソ連やらアメリカやら中国やら
なんであろうとも どれほど軍事にお金かかっているのかと
まあ北朝鮮どうでしょうか
もう収入がないのに 全国の収入 GPO の半分以上
軍事 軍事 軍事 なんでそういう風になってるんですかね
はい なぜ薬の開発より武器開発は優先なのかと考えてほしいんです
薬の開発よりは武器の開発が優先なんです
個人財産さえも まあ緊急
それは私は勝手につけた言葉で
法律用語を見つからなかったんです
忘れちゃったんです 事態が発生すると国に取られる法律はあるのかと
これは日本のことなんです
皆様安心しているんですけど
国家に法律を作っているんです
使う次勝手に使われますよと
最近の法律です 膨大な法律があるのかと
なんで法律はあるわあるわあるわ膨大でしょ
こんな社会生きやすいと思いますかね
簡単であるはずの法律が専門家にも理解できないほど複雑になっているのだと
なぜなっているのだと考えてほしいです
そんなにも複雑 はい 次
社会 工場 学校などの運営も大変厳しい
複雑なものになっているのかと
なんでそうなっているんでしょうかね
子供が学校から帰宅するまで安心することができないの
なんでできないんですかね
薄暗い道を歩くことが怖い
でしょ なんでしょうかね
倒産するはずのない事業などが突然倒産してしまう
それはなぜでしょうかね
はい 次 経営者がと労働者が永遠に対立的な関係を持っているのかと
なぜ持っているのかと考えてほしい
反対でも暴動 反乱 テロ
クーデター 暗殺などがなぜあるのかと
民族差別 言語差別 経済的政治的差別
信仰的差別 なぜあるのかと
これ一人一人膨大に説明しなくちゃいけないけど
ただ一応考えてほしいものなんですよ
誰も考えないだけで なぜ幸せであるはずの家庭は崩壊するのかと
皆様の家庭というわけじゃなくて
結構家庭崩壊しているでしょ
あれなぜでしょうかと
はい 次 まだありますよ
なぜ個人が不平不満に満ちた生き方をしなくてはいけないのかと
なんで我々個人がずっと不平不満で生きてるでしょうに
穏やかじゃないでしょ
心の中は あれって何なのかと
要するに なぜ世界 社会
人生は悩み苦しみのみ目指すのかと考察してみましょう
全てまとめてみると 世界
社会と人生三つの世界も社会も人生そのものも悩み苦しみに満ちているが
それ目指すんですよ 幸福安らぎじゃないんです
それ考えてほしいんですよ
それで答えは簡単です
道徳倫理を無視する傾向が主な原因なのです
今まで言ったすべて道徳を無視することによって現れるのです
簡単ですよ 北朝鮮に至っても全部国の収入が真横まで売ったりして
軍事力 軍事力ばっかりやってるのは道徳破ってますよ
政治家の一人二人が自分の所有物やと家畜動物やと
国民は自分が神様やと思っている
そこで自分こそ世界一強いんだと
日本なんか韓国なんか何のことなく潰されますよ
アメリカなんかもうひどい目に遭いますよ
自慢するんですよ あんなアホったれの思考で国民が飢えているんですよ
だからあれくらい武器を作るんです
テレビは日本から買うのに
日本か中国から買うのに自分たちはミサイルを買います
という世界なんです だから道徳を無視していることですよ
ただ一つの原因  主な原因と書いたのは
まあまあ ちょこちょこ別な原因もたまたま見られますけど
それほど これは主な原因なんです
はい また別なテーマに行きます
じゃあわかるでしょ？道徳といかに大事かということは
道徳を守れば社会はいかに良くなるのかと
個人個人がもう悩み苦しみなく
穏やかで幸福で生きてられるでしょうに
家庭 家族崩壊ないでしょうに
生きにくい社会の 4番目にまた戻ります
自然災害以外の社会の苦しみは人工的です
自然災害以外一切の社会の苦しみは人工的です
人が作ったものです 人は自我主義で己のことしか考えません
欲 怒り 無知の感情で生きていて
慈しみ 思いやり 共存 協力などを実行するどころか
その意味さえも理解していないのです
慈しみの意味さえもわかってないんです
実行してもらおうと思ったらこれはありえないんです
それぐらい人間個人個人でわがまま自己主張なんです
はい 生きにくい社会の 5番目
社会は不道徳で練り上げて構成しているものです
社会っていうのは あのしっかりした組織ですよ
それは不道徳で練り上げているんです
不道徳で固まっているんですよ
したがって生きにくい社会になるのです
たとえ野球クラブを作っても
子供たちはえらい精神的に疲れるでしょうに
何なのかと あれでまた怒り
憎しみ 競争心 もう先輩は後輩いじめとかね
あれこれやと不道徳で練り上げてるんですよ
ただの学校の野球クラブにしたっても
だからみんな苦しいんですよ
したがって 会社は常に崩壊する危機を担っているのです
社会は 社会っていうのは常に崩壊危機があるんです
担っているんです 皆 不幸
不平 不満 恐怖 差別 いじめ
苦しみ 落ち込み 怒り 絶望
挫折などを経験するものです
もっと単語はそれ以上私は知らなかったんですから
それで止まりました もし知ったならもっと書きますけど
これは経験していない人間ないでしょ
これも道徳を守らない結果なんです
社会は生きにくいってことなんです
はい 次に行きます 社会
でも社会は崩壊しないでしょう
崩壊の危機になっているんだけど
崩壊 それは面白いでしょ
社会は崩壊しつつですが
短時間で崩壊はしないのです
なんとか持ちこたえている
しかし 仏典にはやがて不道徳はトラーションリミットというものがありまして
に達したところで完全に崩壊すると記してある
仏教経典に書いてます
社会は完全に崩壊する時期が来るんだよと
そこまで持ちこたえますけど
このいつかというと このトラーンジェーションリミットっていうのはもうもうわからない
私も  臨界点臨界点とか飽和点
そうそうそう 臨界点かな
え？ 許容範囲  え？ 許容範囲
一応まあまあとにかく
なんかでしょうね あまり私は日本語の言葉
そこら辺では勉強してないんです
いわゆるこの忍耐範囲
我慢できるレベルがあるんです
不道徳は このリミット超えちゃうとぶち破れちゃうんです
全て ことごとく もう我々個人で考えてください
我々も個人では我慢する
我慢する 例えば奥さんがうるさい
毎日なんかなんかもう批判ばっかりしている夫
旦那を 旦那は黙っている
でもそれでやがてトラーンジェーションリミットが切れちゃうんです
それで何とかするんですよ
これがとても危ないんです
それで崩壊なんです それから再び道徳を重んじる社会が徐々に開発していくと説く
経典であるんですよ この完全にこのなんか原始のなんか読んでみるとなんかもう核兵器がもう散乱されて崩壊するような
昔はそんなことはなかったんだから
イメージを先行させなくちゃいけないし
まあ空から降るんだよと
黒い雨が それに触れる人々はみんなもうおかしくなっちゃうんだと
互いに動物やとしか思えないんだと
人間だと思わないんだ
それでもみんなの手に武器があるんだと
お互いに残酷に殺し合っちゃうんだ
それで何人かが逃げるんだ
森に 逃げて なんで残酷なことなのかと
また原始社会に戻るんです
我々は互いに親切に優しくして仲良くしましょうということで
また原始社会が現れてきて
これはじわじわと道徳的な社会を通して発展する
発展するんだけど その社会もまた
道徳嫌になっちゃうんだからね
この波があるんですよ
それも変化していますけど
はい 次に行きます くたくたにいじめられてはいるが
道徳はまだ息止めたわけ
息を止めたわけではありません
我々みんな道徳をくたくたいじめて壊してますよ
しかし 道徳も結構あれが強いんですよ
なかなか死なないんですね
だから息は止めてない
生きてるわけじゃないんだけど
息は止めてないんですね
したがって 崩壊しつつある社会が崩壊
完了にはなりません それすごい残念なことでしょうね
我々は道徳を破ってますけど
攻撃しているんだけど
道徳のおかげで生きてるんですよ
だから道徳は守ってるんだから
私は今抗議中は私の部屋は誰も破らないと安心しているんです
もし一欠片も道徳なかったら部屋出られませんよ
いくら鍵かけたって誰か破るかもしれませんから
だから我々は安心してこちらにいるのは社会に道徳があるんだからなんですよ
なのにその道徳を馬鹿にするんです
あまりにも失礼というか
残酷というかね まあとにかく社会は崩壊しつつが崩壊しない理由はそちらにあるんです
そう簡単にそれでお釈迦様の言葉なんですが
それの出典調べるとこでもう時間なくなったのでもうやめちゃったんです
あの 牛車のあの両輪のごとく
懺鬼 ヒリオッタッパですね
によって社会が支えられている
あの社会は車に例えると車には車輪 2つあります
で このように懺と鬼という人間にはちょっとした感情があるんだと
これはヒリオッタッパというんで
パーリ語で あの本当は車輪ではなくて
この車軸を に あの止め金が入れるんですよ
それで車輪がずれない
落ちないんです あの車輪に穴があって
穴に軸が入っちゃうんですね
この軸の前にあの留め金を付けるんです
それで車輪が回っても回っても
このあの留め金のおかげで落ちないんです
車にあるような感じでね
で まあ車ではちょっとややこしいんだからね
古い牛車馬車だったら分かりやすい
そのようにこの懺鬼 ヒリオッタッパであります
それでなんとか社会が崩壊しないだろうでしょうとお釈迦様はおっしゃったんです
見てください 今日 今までの説明であっても
なかなか本にもどこにも書かれてない考え方ですけど
かなり詳しい道徳的な見解でしょ
しかし それは仙部お釈迦様の言葉から私はあのカニングして言ってるんです
はい 次に行きます 非礼っていうのは
あの悪を犯すことを恥じる
悪を犯すことを恥じるんです
これは良いプライドです
あの品格的に優れた生き方を好むこと
まあ面白いこと この暴力主義者たちでも結構品格的に生きていきようとするんですよ
ちゃんと挨拶しなさいとかね
服装はきちんと決まってるとかね
面白いね あの連中 だから人間にはそれはちらちらとあるんだからね
良い意味のプライド それでおッタッパっていうのは鬼ですけど
悪を犯すことは怖がる
社会や法律で裁かれること
死後の不幸などを考えて怖がる
地獄に落ちたくないとか
それは弱い意味の弱気なんです
良い弱気 人間にはたまたま良いプライドも良い弱気も心の中で回転するんですよ
だからなんとかこの社会が持ちこたえているんです
多かれ少なかれ この 2つは人の心にうろついてるものです
はい 次ね 仏教的な解説
仏教的な解説はもう今までの説明はすごい単純になります
怒り 欲などが破壊的で
社会の個人の不幸を招くものだと知っているのに
人は決してそれを制御しようと努まない
その理由は 大体みんな知ってますよ
怒りは良くないとか 欲は良くないとかね
知ってはいるんだけど
誰も制御だけはしない
なぜかというと という答えは
根本的な生きる勝負は貪瞋痴です
貪り怒り愚痴です 不道徳的に生きることは自然の流れです
だから道徳を犯すことっていうのは
我々自然の流れですよ
頭では分かってますよ
怒りは良くないと でも心では分かってないんです
感情の世界では かわいそうに
この感情 その感情は真理を知らないという根本的な無知
無明から生じる この貪瞋痴の感情はもう根本的に真理を知らないという無知があるんです
そこから現れるんですよ
それだけの解説です はい
次に行きます で 悪の感情に対して対立的に善の感情も発生する
それから我々の社会人として
この 2つも絡み合ってるんですよ
良いことをしたい 悪いことをしたい
良いことをしたい 悪いことをしたいという気持ちがいつでも絡み合ってるんです
無明の土台の上で 悪と善の対立的に現れる感情の波に乗って人が生きている
結構難しいですね 文章は理解するには
人間の生き方というのは無明の土台で生きているんです
そこでわかりやすく言えば書いていると思います
悪いことをしている時
良いことをしたくなるし
良いことをしている時
悪いことをしたくなる
でしょ なんか随分 例えば小さな社会ね
作ってすごく仲良くいると
なんかふざけたことしたくなっちゃうんです
ふざけて悪いことばっかりしていると
いい加減いいことでもしようかなと思っちゃうんです
そうやってこの人間の感情がもう何て言いますか
変換して変換していくんです
私それ言ってるんですよ
たまにいいんじゃないかという生き方ですよ
いつでもたまにいいんじゃないかと皆さんは言ってるでしょ
例えばもうもうばくばく打ちって言うんですか
爆撃爆撃とかね まあたまにいいんじゃないですかと
それは悪いことをたまにしようということでしょう
いいこともそうなんですよ
悪いことばっかりしても
たまにいいことでもしようよとか思っちゃうんですよ
たまにいいんじゃないかという論理でみんな生きてるんです
ずっととはないんです
はい それで次 最後のテーマなんですね
これは結構伸びちゃいます
この生きにくい社会を生き抜くということ
社会全体の改良という考えは成り立ちません
社会全体を改良しようというのはありえないんです
原因は個人の心にあるんだから
仏教的に解説すれば 貪瞋痴は私の心にあるし
あなたの心にもあるんだから
個人の心に貪瞋痴と無明の上に貪瞋痴が乗ってるんです
だから原因は個人にあるんですよ
個人が努力すればその人が幸福になる
個人の数を増やしていけばいいのです
だから我々は個人でいい人間になる
なってもう一人個人を増やす
もう一人個人を増やすと
そういうことで社会はいい社会になるんです
道徳を守る個人に 周りの人々に
親しい人々にも理解してもらう
賛同してもらう 実行してもらう
間違ってます 打ち間違えます
という義務があるんです
例えば一人でいい人間で頑張るんじゃないんですよ
義務があるんです 自分の親しい人にも理解してくださいと
私はこういうことをやってますよと
いきなりあなたもやりなさいと言わなくてもいいんですよ
で あんたも賛成してくださいと
悪くないでしょうと そういう風にゆっくりゆっくり周りの人々にも教えてあげて
納得してもらって 賛同してもらって
実行してもらう そういうことしか道徳を守る方法はないんですよ
その義務があるんです
それが慈しみっていうものなんです
だから この良いことをする人間
例えば嘘を言わないとか
戒律を守るとかね 明らかに個人の行為なんですけど
戒律を受けた途端 もう一つ義務がついているんです
周りにも 自分の親しい人々にも賛成してもらいなさいよと
勝手にやるなよと で しゃばって自我を張ってやるなよと
そこは仏教は厳しいんです
だから この人殺しまでして伝道活動
布教活動しなくても 仏教はすごく滑らかに広がったんです
あれ慈しみって はい 次に行きます
ん？これできたっけ はい
三十ですね で 勇気のある個人は世界に対抗ということで
あまりまあ大胆な意味じゃないんですよ
だから道徳を守るということは
世界に対する対抗なんですよ
だって世界で一人も道徳に賛成する人はいないんだから
大変なことなんです 道徳的に生きようということは
世界を相手にして対抗するようなものです
また 自分の心とも戦わなくてはならないんですよ
世界は批判するは道徳のある人のことを
自分の心の貪瞋痴もいい加減やめなさいと言うわ
だから自分の心とも戦わなくちゃいけないし
世界のことも無視してはいけなくちゃいけないんです
法則的に見ると 道徳が勝利を得るので
これは必ず勝利を得る対抗です
でも心配する必要はないんです
世界に対して対抗しても勝つんです
なぜかというと 道徳が勝利を得るということはもう法則なんです
そんな難しいことじゃないでしょうね
皆様が安心してこの授業に来たのは
家には悪者に入らないだろうという安心感あるんだから
でしょ それ道徳なんです
周りが守ってくれる 自分が守ってないんだけど
だから道徳っていうのは勝利を得る道であって
生きる道であるということは明らかな法則なんです
だから 個人が世界がやめろと言っても
道徳を守ると勝利を得るんです
決して負けない 幸福になります
はい 次 で それ道徳を守る時の心構え
で まずちょっとした質問ですね
どちらを選択しますか？と
これはちょっとあまり面白い質問じゃないんだけどね
まああの ただ象徴的にあなたは泣いてるからという
泣いてるっていうことは象徴的な言葉なんです
何を選ぶんですか？私も泣く
二番目 さらにあなたを泣かせる
いわゆる応援する そうでしょう
もう悲しいでしょうとかね
もっと泣いてくださいと賛成すること
で あるいはあなたは泣いている時はあなたに攻撃する
激しく反対する この馬が何で泣くのか
いい加減にしろとか 泣いたらただで済むぞとかね
で反撃する 三番 四番目
私は微笑んであなたの微笑みを期待するということ
相手の影響を受けず 逆の影響を与えよう
与えるようにする 与えようとする
これは番目の選択なんです
では どちらを選ぶでしょうかね
はい 選んでください まあと言っても
まあもうみんなもう あれだからね
恥かきたくないんだから
まあ選ばないと思いますけど
普通はみんなそれどちらでも選んで生活してるんですよ
これ正解 人間やってる世界から見ると正解はないんです
よく日本の社会で見るのは私も泣くという選択なんですね
一緒に泣くことはすごいすごい良いことやと思っちゃうんですよ
で 番目もよくやるし 応援する
でもさらに問題を悪化させちゃう
もう三番目もよくよくやりますよ
四番目だけはね なかなか誰もやってる形跡はありません
しかし答えは四番です
はい 次に行きます ブッダの推薦は四です
私は微笑んであなたの微笑みを期待する
相手の影響を受けず 逆の影響を与える与えるようにする
これは微笑 あの泣くということの代わりに何でもいいんですよ
怒りやら憎しみやら落ち込みやら何でもいいんです
だから象徴的に泣くという言葉を使ったんです
人が怒ってると その通りその通り
お前当たり前怒ってそんなこと言うと誰でも怒るぞと言って追い詰めるんじゃないんですよ
なんでお前バカ怒るのかと言って攻撃するんでもないんですよ
本人が怒ってるんだから
そんなことにたっても
あんたが怒るんだから私も怒るぞと言って一緒になるんじゃないんですよ
そうではなくて まあ怒るのはわかるんだけどね
まあ私ならそれぐらいでは怒れませんよと
気持ちはわかるんだけど
私なら怒りませんよと
怒ってね 別に何がいいっていうこともないしね
苦しいだけだからね まあなんとかして笑いましょうということが仏教的なやり方なんです
それがまず覚えておいてください
で 皆嘘つきからこそ 私は嘘をつかないように
えっと 読めない 捨ても励む
戒める 努力する 精進する
挑戦する 試してみる これも経典にある単語を適当に羅列したんです
これが仏教的なやり方なんです
泣くっていうことを今嘘にしてください
人が嘘をつく では私も嘘をつくですかね
ではもっと嘘を言いなさいと私は応援するんですかね
あるいは攻撃するんです
なんで嘘つくのかと どちらに正しくないんですよ
4番目選ばなくちゃいけないんです
だから個人が人が嘘をついているのを見ると
個人が社会が皆嘘をついているんだからこそ
私は嘘をつかないんだ
それが励めないと 捨てめないと
戒めないとできるものじゃない
努力しないとできるものじゃない
精進しないでできるものじゃない
挑戦しないとできるものじゃない
試せないとできるものじゃないと思わなくちゃいけないんです
だから道徳を守るっていうことは
社会を相手にして抵抗することなんですよ
これぐらい勇気が必要なんです
これは反面教師的なアプローチで
皆やるからしょうがないという弱気者の態度ではない
道徳の場合は お釈迦様はこれもうちょっと態度デカくしなさいと
弱気者にはできませんと言っているんです
はい えーと 今日はあるんでしょうかね
はい すぐ見ます で これであの一つ経典を読んでみますということで
全部は読めません あの
生き 抜く人の虎の巻 例えば人が個人が真面目に道徳を守って生活しようと思っても
これ生半可の気持ちではできないんですよ
みんな反対するんだから
例えば子供があまりにも全然嘘をつかないで正直に大人になってくると親が困るんですよ
うちの子はあまりにもバカ正直で困ったなと
そんなもんですよ 社会っていうのは
小さい時は嘘をつくなよと言ったのに
親はやっぱり社会からやられるかもしれませんという心配なんですよ
だって社会は道徳を守ってないんだから
道徳の立場がないんですよ
親が真剣真面目に子供に嘘をつくなよと言うんですよ
言うんだけど 社会では嘘をつかないと生活できないんですね
社会に賛同して生きることはできないんです
しかし 社会に抵抗して大勝利を収めることもできます
社会を手に取って負かすことを
負かすことできます 道徳を守れば
この大勝利っていうのは
経済的でも社会的でも権力的でも
どんな立場でも勝利を得られます
どんな社会でも道徳者
道徳を守る人には立場があるんです
それでそれを説明している経典があります
マッジムニ会の 8番目の経典サンレイカすったという本です
で 中部経典というところで 8番目を調べれば
皆様は日本語訳で読まれると思います
それも後半から読みになっております
前半は難しい 本一つは作ってはあります
これあの経典と言ったって
これはこの声出して読み上げる経典なんです
いわゆる読経というかね
読み上げるための経典なんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃったものです
だから調子を合わせて単語を合わせていろいろすごい気分よく読み上がれるように作っていて
パーリ語だったら結構ものすごい勇気が湧いてくるんです
読むと で 作ったのは作ったんです
これは日本のお寺のお坊さんがお金を出して皆で皆にこの法説をして配ってくださいと作った本で
結構お金かかったんですよ
紙まですごい良い紙 我々普通安い紙で本作ってますけど
これ無料で配れるものだから
なんかこの道徳に誰でも反対するんだから
面白くない本やとみんな全然誰も読んでくれた気配はしないんです
なのに本 1冊も今ないんです
むちゃくちゃいらん入れませんという人にも強引にあげるのは見たことがありますからね
まあ本も良くないんですけど
本当はこの本はこの宝物のごとく毎日声出して読み上げた方が解説もありますけどね
ものすごいそれだけで立派な人間になります
ものすごい勇気が湧いてきます
この経典で人はたとえ修行瞑想しても禅定の体験を得ても
道徳的な問題を解決したことにはならないと前半で強調する
この修行やなんかやりやがったっても
あなたは完全に道徳的な問題が解決してないんだよと
禅定しているんだとかね
もう世界にそういうケースいくらでもありますからね
これは前半でそこを強調する
修行者さえも一歩間違えば不道徳的な感情を引き起こす恐れがある
普通の人の場合は言うまでもありません
そこは前半のポイントなんです
後半では解決策を説かれています
この経典の後半で どうやって解決するのかと
で ポイントはみんなやってるんだから私もやるしかないでしょうというあの弱気ものをやめなさいと
みんなやってるんだからあなたはやらないんだよと
みんな嘘をついてるんだから
君は嘘をつかない人間になろうと
みんな泥棒やってるんだから
与えないものを取ってるんだから
君は与えられてないものを取るなよという態度なんです
それに頑張りなさい それに励みなさい
それに挑戦しなさい あるところで美しい言葉があって
君たちこのチュンダというお坊さんに個人的に言うんですよ
チュンダにこう言うんだよ
チュンダ 道が 2つある
하나는とても危険な道
하나는すごい安全な道
それで君に試してみるために道が 2つある
生きてみるために道が 2つある
チュンダよ だから良い悪い道があるんだからこそ
君が良い道を楽しむんだよ
それで人が嘘をつくという悪い
悪い道を歩んでいる みんな世界中
だからこそチュンダ君は嘘をつかないという道を歩むなよ
歩むようという風な すごい感動的でインパクト強くもう教えられてます
はい 進みます 進みます
三十四 これからこの経典の一部
まあただ読み上げるだけで終了したいと思います
これ一部ですよ このほんの一部
そのまま写したんです
それではチュンダよ このように戒めるべきでです
これパーリ語でサーリプッタ・カーラニョという
他人は他者に害を与えるが
我々は加害者には加害者にならないように戒めましょう
他人は殺生するが 我々は殺生しないようにと戒めましょう
他人は与えられていないものを取るが
我々は与えられていないものを取らないようにと戒めましょう
はい 次 他人は性的な関係を持つ
これは出家に チュンダお坊さんが出家だからね
あの 在家の方々にはもうよこしまなことをするなよというのを戒律です
他人は性的な関係を持つが
我々は性的な関係を持たないようにと戒めましょう
他人は嘘をつくが 我々は嘘をつかないようにと戒めましょう
他人は陰口を言うが 我々は陰口を言わないようにと戒めましょう
声が美しい方がいれば代わりに大砲で読んであげてもよろしいんだけど
どなたか ダダさん読んでくれますか？ どうせどうせ
大きい声で  他人は 他人は暴言を吐くが
我々は暴言を吐かないようにと戒めましょう
他人は無駄話をするが
我々は無駄話を  間違ってますね
無駄話をしないようにと戒めましょう
他人は強欲になるが 我々は強欲にならないようにと戒めましょう
他人は激怒するが 我々は激怒しないようにと戒めましょう
他人は邪見を持つが 我々は正見を持てるようにと戒めましょう
他人は  邪見  邪見するが
我々は正見を持てるようにと戒めましょう
少々説明入れます この邪見っていうのは
この間違ってる考え方ですよ
妄想なんですよ 怒り 憎しみ
これで精神的に病気になるんですよ
昨日もずっと徹底的に言ったんですけど
この一切の精神病はこの妄想の結果やと
これを邪見と仏教で言ってるんですよ
怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬 こんなものでずっと妄想する
お釈迦様は正しい思考しなさいと
慈しみとかね 欲から離れることとかね
やってくださいと言ってるんです
はい  他人は邪語をするが
我々は正語を持てるようにと戒めましょう
他人は邪業をするが 我々は
邪語 邪語をするが 我々は正語をするようにと戒めましょう
他人は 邪命をするが 我々は正命をするようにと戒めましょう
それで説明します あの邪業とは十四番目は普通の行為なんですね
体でやっている行為 悪いことみんなやってますよと
体でも我々はやらないことをするんだと
邪命っていうのはこの職業ですね
書いてます 説明は はい
他人は邪精進をするが
我々は正精進をするようにと戒めましょう
他人は邪念を持つが 我々は正念を持てるようにと戒めましょう
他人は邪定を育むが 我々は正定を育むようにと戒めましょう
それで注書いてますから
この邪精進というのは犯罪ね
罪を犯すために一生懸命頑張っているでしょう
もう罪も簡単に犯せませんだからね
そういう努力は努力だと思わない
仏教は それから邪念というのは
あの あの これ正念 正しくサンガサティのことで気づくことなんですね
邪念というのは精神的に混乱を引き起こす
頭が悪くなる考え方なんですね
あれやこれはとかね 邪定ということは禅定のことなんですけど
悪いことをする時 我我を忘れて集中する
これもなんか禅定と同じ似てるんだけど
とんでもない邪定なんです
はい  他人は邪智者であるが
我々は正智者になれるようにと戒めましょう
他人は邪解脱を目指すが
我々は正解脱を目指すようにと戒めましょう
他人は怠けと眠気に陥るが
我々は怠けと眠気を断ち切るようにと戒めましょう
他人はよく混乱するが
我々は混乱しないようにと戒めましょう
他人は他人は懐疑的であるが
我々は懐疑を断ち切るようにと戒めましょう
他人は怒るが 我々は怒らないようにと戒めましょう
他人は恨むが 我々は恨まないようにと戒めましょう
他人は他者の徳を軽視するが
我々は軽視しないようにと戒めましょう
他人は張り合うが 我々は張り合わないようにと戒めましょう
他人は嫉妬するが 我々は嫉妬しないようにと戒めましょう
他人は物惜しみをするが
我々は物惜しみをしないようにと戒めましょう
他人は見栄を張るが 我々は見栄を張らないようにと戒めましょう
他人は善人ぶるが 我々は善人ぶらないようにと戒めましょう
他人は頑固である 我々は頑固にならないようにと戒めましょう
他人は高慢であるが 物惜しみをするが
我々は高慢にならないようにと戒めましょう
またちょっと直してください
ちょっと待って 間違いあります
これ消し忘れたところがあります
今直しておいた方が また三十三から
他人は高慢であるが 我々は高慢にならないようにと戒めましょう
他人は反抗的であるが
我々は素直になるようにと戒めましょう
他人は悪友と付き合うが
我々は善友と付き合うようにと戒めましょう
他人は怠るが 我々は怠らないようにと戒めましょう
他人は確信を持っていないが
我々は確信を持つようにと戒めましょう
他人は悪を恥じないが
我々は悪を恥じるようにと戒めましょう
他人は悪を恐れないが
我々は悪を恐れるようにと戒めましょう
他人は善学であるが 我々はよく学ぶようにと戒めましょう
他人は怠けるが 我々は励み精進するようにと戒めましょう
他人は不注意であるが
我々は気づきを絶やさないようにと戒めましょう
他人は無知であるが 我々は知恵が備わるようにと戒めましょう
他人は自分の主観に取り憑かれ
しがみつき 捨てられないでいるが
我々は自分の主観にとらわれず
しがみつくことなく 簡単に捨てられるようにと戒めましょう
それで四十四の項目が出たんです
そこで仏教でいう道徳はそういうものなんです
一般的に知っているものよりは結構幅広いんですよ
あの微妙にでも人が不幸になるものはすべて不道徳にしているんです
嘘を言わないだけじゃないんですよ
怠けることでも あまり勉強しないことでも
仏教では不道徳なんです
だからこの四十四項目
仏教的な難しい項目もありましたけど
でも誰にでも守られるものなんですよ
一応読み上げただけでも
なんとなく勇気が湧いてくるんじゃないかなと思いますよ
まあもし専門家が読み上げたらみんな感動すると思いますよ
そういうアナウンサーみたいにね
まあもう矢田さんはね
まあただいきなり頼まれたけど
で この四十四番目はこの一番大事なところというかね
誰でも気をつけた方がいいポイントなんです
この主観に取り憑かれ
しがみつき 捨てられないということは
人がそれで終わりなんですよ
全くの成長しない 自分の主観で取り憑かれていると
だからものすごい危ない不道徳なんですよ
我々にいろいろ主観がありますよ
別にそれってどうってことじゃないんですよ
主観があっても取り憑かれてはならない
悪いなと変だなとわかった時点で捨てちゃう
それで成長していくんですよ
人は向上して進化していくんですよ
だからこれが本当は道徳の第一にしなくちゃいけないことなんです
だから結局は誰でも当たり前に知ってるところから始めて
仏教 ブッダは誰も気づかない一番大事な道徳で四十四で終わっているんです
まあとにかくこうやってこの読み上げて
でもなんとなく守りたいなという気分にさせてくれる
それで我々を応援してくれるんですよ
大変なことだから はい
まとめます 人の成功 向上
発展 幸福 解脱を妨げる一切の行為は不道徳になっているのです
人の成功であろうが 向上であろうが
発展であろうが 幸福であろうが
幸せ 何でもいいんですよ
人が期待するものは それから仏教的に言えば解脱
そういうものは妨げるものはいかなるものでも不道徳なんです
それで この不道徳は社会は大好きですから
矛盾 混乱 不調和が絶えないのです
社会では矛盾やら混乱やら不調和っていうのは絶えないでしょう
なぜかというと 不道徳は大好きなんですよ
不道徳は大好きですけど
成長したい 発展したいとか思っている
幸せになりたいとも思っている
むちゃくちゃですよ だから社会には混乱があるんです
矛盾があるんです 生き抜くためには勇気と覚悟が必要です
この生きにくい社会で生き抜くためには
はい  すぐ終わります それで長い時間でしたから
長い講義でしたから 忍耐強く聞いていただいたことに感謝します
英語で書いたんです ということで
今日のテーマは終了いたします
どうもありがとう [背景音]